yo how's it going everybody
International Master Danny wrench here
back with another installment for
chess.com YouTube channel in deciding
which direction to go next as we are
running out of Mainline tournament
weapons to give to you all in this
awesome playlist we have I decided to
cover the English opening which is one
of the longest standing most
positionally sound openings not the most
popular weapon when compared to one E4
or 1 D4 but one C4 which is officially
the English move order does have its
merits one of the main advantages behind
the English is that white has a couple
different options to reach setups that
black can't really prevent meaning when
you play E4 you're sort of putting the
ball in Black's Court does he want E5
does he want the PS does he want the
Caro does he want the Sicilian does he
want the alakin right so black sort of
has the option to choose his line of
defense whereas when you're playing the
English black certainly has his options
in terms of his approach and we're going
to try to cover the three main ones very
quickly but white has the opportunity to
develop into structures and into
positions that really do not depend on
what approach black is choosing what
exactly am I referring to well let's say
black plays C5 which is a symmetrical
English just just repeating White's move
on C4 the next few moves white has the
option of playing mainly heading into
positions such as the B vinck English
really really have no bearing on on the
moves black is choosing after Knight to
C3 which increases the control over D5
black has several options to show you
Knight C6 G6 Knight F6 but on any one of
these if white chooses to play G3 Bishop
G2 and then complete his development by
increasing his grip on the center
putting the Knight on E2 castling and
completing the bot vinning English with
D3 you're looking at a position that is
very solid white has has the potential
for space on both sides of the board
whenever you look at Pawn chains those
usually tell you which direction to
attack in and so one advantage of the
bot vinic is that it's sort of
controlling both sides of the board
white has options to expand expand and
gain space on both sides of the board
you see that this is a very solid choice
for white again let's say we play C4 and
black plays E5 if white wants to play
Knight C3 and G3 and complete his
development in a very similar manner he
has the option to do so and it really
doesn't depend on what black is doing
Bishop to B4 is one move here that does
put a little more pressure on white to
deal with the threat but white has good
variations after the move Knight to D5
also what should be considered is that
the move D5 is possible transposing into
an open Sicilian reversed and often
times white is going to be pretty
comfortable in this type of position as
as I said it's an open Sicilian reverse
which means if it's playable for black I
guess you could say it's playable for
white up at up at one tempo up a
significant move right so the advantage
of the English other than the basic most
fundamental things behind it that it
controls critical squares in the center
like a sicilian would and leaves that
leaves the center pawns flexible to do
different things is that if white
chooses lines like the bod vinck English
he has the option to reach a structure
or a totally playable position that has
no bearing and it can can't really be
affected by the by the weapons that
black is choosing the one real exception
to that from Black's perspective is if
black chooses the idea of of transposing
into Queen Pawn games whether that be by
E6 and D5 or whether that might even be
by
C6 and D5 going into a slav or
potentially after E4 transposing into a
Carol con if black chooses to play for a
challenging move such as D5 in the
center early on then white will not be
able to just shut down his critical
thinking skills and develop into a bod
venic English structure just
automatically he'll have to do something
about Black's decision to play for D5
and that's one of the reasons why for
more experienced instructors or coaches
like myself I don't like when my younger
students start playing chess with the
move C4 because of Black's options to
transpose into both E4 whether it be the
kocon or D4 openings it makes it
difficult to try to have a young player
playing an opening like the English when
they don't even know the Carol con or
the Queen's Gambit you see you're sort
of opening the door for them to be
tricked and and and transposed into
other Mainline weapons but if you're an
experienced tournament player out there
or if you feel like you're willing to
take the risk that your opponent may not
transpose and you're attracted to the
idea that once again I'll do something
different that black can play different
things but we can reach a similar
structure every time if we choose again
seeing another move order for black but
seeing that it has no bearing on White's
ability to get the B vinx structure then
you might like this idea of adding the
English opening to your repertoire there
are other ways of course other than the
bot vinic English to play similar lines
with G3 but rather than E4 perhaps E3
and KN G to E2 as well as developing the
nf3 but as this video is designed as an
intro into the basic advantages of
playing the English we'll leave it at
that for now and if you're interested
there's actually a video series going on
on the main site right now by
Grandmaster Roman ginji hash on the
English and blacks different options
against it and if that's something that
interests you then we hope to see you
around on the main site thanks for being
here I will see you around on chess.com